[Musik]
am samstag findet das
militärmusikfestival
2022 auf der seebühne im
burgenländischen möbelstadt
nicht
wo man auch musik nicht so genießen
konnte nämlich nicht live genießen
konnte wie gut das tut und dann noch in
dem bewusstsein gutes tun zu können und
zu hören weil er ohne licht ins dunkel
insbesondere auch für die ukraine hilfe
gespendet wird das tut umso besser die
damen und herren des bundesheers
sozusagen hat einmal mehr dass sie nicht
nur gegen lawinen können gegen
hochwasser gegen feuer gegen pandemien
sondern das herz kennen sie kennen
wunderschön musizieren dass wir heute
wieder mal sehen gefeiert wird an diesem
abend eine kooperation die schon ein
halbes jahrhundert lang andauert 50
jahre licht ins dunkel mit dem
österreichischen bundesheer ich glaube
es könnte keine größere
erfolgsgeschichte geben als die
kooperation zwischen österreichischen
bundesheer und licht ins dunkel das hat
von anfang an bis heute hervorragend
funktioniert über den erfolg dieser
kooperation könnte wohl auch eher ein
lied singen licht ins dunkel und nachbar
in not mitbegründer der 2016 verstorbene
kurt bergmann sein spirit lebt heute
weiter in seinem enkel hauptmann jakob
erdmann
der letzten jahre gemacht und auch vor
allem
auch tatsächlich mit dienstlichen bezug
licht ins dunkel und das österreichische
bundesheer eine erfolgsstory die von
generation zu generation fortgesetzt
wird und das soll auch so bleiben
[Musik]
mit dabei beim militärmusikfestival
2022 in mörbisch sind rund 6000
besucherinnen und besucher die meisten
sind begeisterte fans einige wenige
hören und sehen dass zum ersten mal
vorher gefragt
und haben die generalprobe sind mit
seiner musik da kann nichts anfangen
aber was da abgeht das ist sehr sehr
lässig nach dem jäger selbst auch in
eine musikkapelle gespielt habe in
meinen jugendjahren
neben besonderen bezug gehabt aber die
militärmusik und auch diese spirit
besonders wenn man die pandemie bedingte
zweijährige auszeit der militärmusik mit
einbezieht ja natürlich ich muss schon
sagen wir konnten jetzt ja die letzten
zwei jahre kaum mit gemeinsam musizieren
und man merkte schon man braucht dann
wird eine gewisse anlaufphase es wie
beim sport und auch wie beim
motorradfahren damit im motoren und die
maschinen wieder anspringen und
dementsprechend gut funktionieren ich
glaube dass die jungen damen und herren
sehr motiviert sind und natürlich an die
fast die doppelte leistung bringen und
ein telefonat sehr viel zusammen geprobt
muss man natürlich auch sagen nahezu die
doppelte spenden leistung wird nur knapp
verfehlt bis zum rand wohl sind an
diesem abend die spendenboxen freundlich
die studie zeigt einfach davon welch
großartige partnerschaft ist das
bundesheer des films schutz und hilfe
steht licht ins dunkel das war's für
menschen die unverschuldet in notlagen
daher haben und das ist eine so
erfolgreiche partnerschaft
und das unterstreichen
58.000 643 euro und 93 cent gespendet
für licht ins dunkel